- [Teacher] In the last
video we discussed the great
compromise made at the
Constitutional Convention in 1787,
where delegates who were
trying to craft a new
governmental system for the
United States agreed on how
the legislative branch of the
government would be set up,
and the agreement they made was
that it would be a two house
or bicameral legislature with
a House of Representatives,
where the representatives
would be apportioned
based on state population,
and then a Senate where
every state would get two
senators regardless of its size.
This is just one example
of how the framers
of the constitution tried to
introduce a notion of balance.
In this video, I wanna zoom
out a little bit and look at
the broader constitution,
because the legislative branch
was really only one part of it.
In fact, there are seven more
articles of the constitution.
So here, I'd like to spend
some time taking a closer look
at some of the other articles,
paying special attention
to the executive branch
and the judicial branch,
but before we do that, I
just want to take a moment
to marvel at the size of the constitution.
Not because it's so big,
but because it's so small.
This is the first page
of the constitution,
famously starting with, "We
the people," but the entire
original constitution
could fit on four pages.
Compare that to the constitutions
of many other nations
which are hundreds of pages long,
and I think the idea here
in having a constitution
that's really only seven articles long
was that it was gonna set down principles.
This wasn't going to be a
whole set of laws that outlined
everything that a state
should do in any situation
but rather a set of
broad ideas around which
lawmaking decisions could happen.
In a way, you could
think of the constitution
as being kind of broad
enough to be flexible.
They spoke in larger
generalities that could be
applied to many different situations,
and I think the proof that
this was a good way to think
about putting together a
constitution is just in the fact
that we'd still have
this constitution today,
more than 200 years after
it was written in 1787.
The US Constitution is the
oldest constitution in the world
that is still in effect
at the national level.
I think that's a pretty big deal.
How did this constitution work?
Well, let's look a little bit
more closely at these first
three articles and the branches
of government they created.
One of the ways that the
framers of the constitution
attempted to remedy the problems
caused by the single branch
government under the
Articles of Confederation
was creating a three branch government.
One branch, established in Article 1,
would be the Congress
and within this building
is the House of
Representatives and the Senate.
And this would be in
the eyes of the framers,
really the most powerful of the branches.
They gave Congress the power to make law,
to tax, to raise an army, to coin money.
They really envisioned
that most of the day to day
operations and most of
the power of government
would fall under the duties of Congress,
but one thing that the
Articles of Confederation
had lacked was a powerful executive,
so the second branch of government,
established in Article 2
is the executive branch,
the head of which is the president.
The job of the executive
would be to enforce
or carry out the laws made by Congress,
and that would include doing
things like waging war.
Remember that the first
president was George Washington,
who had been the General of
the Revolutionary Armies,
but the president could also
kind of have the front lines
on dealing with foreign nations,
so negotiating treaties,
and would also have the power
of appointing many government officials.
And lastly, the third branch
would be the judicial branch
of government, established in Article 3.
The head of the judicial branch
would be the Supreme Court,
the highest court in the land.
Of course, there are
many other smaller courts
below it at the state and district level.
The Supreme Court's job,
along with other courts,
would be to interpret the
law, to see whether or not
things done by Congress and the president
fell within the bounds
of the constitution.
And the framers really thought
that the judicial branch
would end up being the
weakest branch of government,
although both the presidency
and the Supreme Court
have grown in power over the years.
Now, this is an incredibly brief overview
of these three branches.
These articles include lots more in them
about the specific powers
of each of these branches
and the kinds of
requirements one would need
to become a representative or president,
so I highly recommend
that you read more about
the Constitution and
check out these articles.
But what I want you to get out
of this is that the framers
here were trying to separate
the powers of government,
so they wanted to make sure that to avoid
having too much power in government.
Remember that they are trying
to escape from the monarchy.
They want to make sure
that government power
is kind of diffused among
these three branches
with the idea that they're
going to have to argue
with each other to get things
done, they're going to have to
cooperate with each
other to get things done,
so the separation of
powers is one of the key
principles of the Constitution.
Another key principle
is checks and balances.
What do I mean by checks and balances?
Well, this is the idea
that each of the branches
of government has the power
to check in the sense of stop,
like checkmate in chess, the
other branches of government.
I think of this as kind of like a giant
governmental game of
rock, paper, scissors.
Now, there are many ways
that these branches can
check each other, but I just
wanna give a couple of quick
examples to help you understand
what that might be like.
Alright, say that Congress makes a law,
and the president doesn't like that law.
The president can use the power
of the veto to kill that law,
and if Congress gets annoyed
enough with the president,
they might use their power
to impeach the president.
What about the judicial branch?
The judicial branch's
main checking function
is declaring laws unconstitutional.
The president or Congress may put through
a law that the Supreme Court says
is not consistent with the Constitution.
The judicial branch can then kill that law
by declaring it unconstitutional.
What happens if the other
branches are unhappy
with the judicial branch?
One way that the president
can check the judicial branch
is through appointing judges.
This would kind of change
the composition of the court,
the people on the court, and so over time,
the presidency can influence
who is on the Supreme Court
and how they rule on laws.
And lastly, if Congress isn't
happy with the Supreme Court,
they might be able to impeach justices,
or change jurisdiction
of the lower courts.
In this way, like the
separation of powers,
the framers intended to make sure that
one branch couldn't get too powerful,
because it would be able to
check the other branches.
You could really think of
this as being a brilliant way
of harnessing peoples' natural inclination
to look out for themselves.
As rivalries developed,
as people tried to do
what they thought was
best, they could help keep
government honest by
fighting among themselves,
and as they all strove
and checked each other,
it would keep all of government
from becoming too powerful.